[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le grand jt
des territoires sur vos chaînes locales
et régionales et sur tv5 monde
voici les titres de l'actualité de cette
édition le gouvernement demande aux
éducateurs spécialisés de s'impliquer
dans la surveillance des quartiers
sensibles au portage dans ce journal de
tl7 qu'a rencontré ces hommes et ces
femmes qui exercent un métier difficile
mais essentiel des images rares dans ce
journal nous partirons dans les hauts de
france tous les neuf mois l'armée
américaine procède à la relève des
troupes stationnées en europe
la chaîne nous et nos partenaires ont
assisté à ces manoeuvres spectaculaires
qui implique vous allez le voir une
logistique peu comme une sédentarité
malbouffe l'obésité parfois tabou est
devenue l'une des problématiques très
importante de santé publique dans nos
sociétés nous verrons des images
spectaculaires de l'évacuation par grue
en occitanie de cet homme de 300 kg
hospitalisé mais qui aujourd'hui
heureusement va mieux et puis vous
voulez rouler en voiture de luxe ou de
collection mais vous pensez que vous
n'en avez pas les moyens et bien tv7 à
peut-être trouvé une solution compatible
avec vos budgets pour le week-end de
frais nouveau verre en fin de journal
vous le savez ces derniers jours la
tension est palpable dans certains
quartiers dits sensibles
le gouvernement surveille de près la
montée de la violence et demande aux
éducateurs spécialisés de rapporter les
faits lorsque ces tensions se présente
sur le terrain mais aussi leurs
inquiétudes et leurs préoccupations la
ligérienne
anne-marie fauvez qu'a rencontré les
équipes de tl7 est aussi présidente du
comité national de liaison des acteurs
de la prévention spécialisée et pour
elle c'est clair la crise sanitaire et
notamment le couvre-feu joue un rôle
dans l' escalade de la violence
reportage d'anthony vers pillon pour la
télévision de la loire il faut encore
tenir quatre à six semaines
cette petite phrase prononcée par le
président de la république hier au sujet
du couvre feu pourrait avoir un impact
important
les jeunes vivent de plus en plus mal
les restrictions dues à la crise
sanitaire
un constat largement relayée par les
éducateurs spécialisés sur le terrain
confronté à plusieurs impasses la
souffrance qu'on rencontre chez ces
jeunes forcément génère
génère de la violence donc c'est pas un
phénomène qui nous surprend et des
acteurs de terrain qui constate aussi
une hausse des violences après la rixe
mortelle en essonne au point de faire
remonter ces inquiétudes auprès du
ministère de la ville qui les a
consultés hier il ya plus de bagarre il
n'ya plus d'utilisation d'armes que ce
soit des armes à feu ou que ce soit des
couteaux et évidemment la crise
sanitaire renforce cette agressivité
il ya des logements inadaptés dans
lesquels il faut qu'ils restent
il ya peu de perspectives d'avenir donc
tout ça fait qu'effectivement ça
s'explique une montée en grade un peu
moins présent dans la loire malgré tout
et qui s'explique par un tissu
associatif fort dans le département il
ya beaucoup d'associations dans la loire
il ya beaucoup d'associations sur les
quartiers qui interviennent il ya aussi
une présence forte des voisins donc du
coup ça ça maintient le lien social
tous reste donc vigilant mais bonne
nouvelle pour eux le plan de relance
prévoit l'embauché de 300 postes
supplémentaires dans la prévention
spécialisée pour accompagner la jeunesse
voilà de nombreux rassemblements ont eu
lieu partout en france et en bretagne à
l'occasion de la journée internationale
des droits des femmes à lorient
d'ailleurs ils étaient 150 samedi
dernier à avoir répondu à l'appel des
syndicats est sur le chemin du cortège
des nouveaux noms de rues ont été
apposés des noms plus féminin vous aviez
patrigeon de tébéo la chaîne du groupe
le télégramme étaient sur place
renommer les rues et places lorientaise
car trop peu portent des noms féminins
-2 6%
c'est le symbole choisi cette année pour
le rassemblement de lutte pour le droit
des femmes
permettre aux femmes de reprendre leur
place dans la rue il n'a pas le choix
on n'a pas le choix et on fait pour nos
enfants demain aujourd'hui et demain
150 personnes suivaient le cortège et
les présentations de farine emblématique
au gré des rues au fil des collages
au-delà de cette action se sont encore
et toujours les mêmes inégalités qui
sont pointés du doigt toute chose on
pourrait parler des inégalités
salariales qui persiste on pourrait
parler aussi des inégalités de
représentation en fait dans l'espace
public dans l'histoire dans les manuels
scolaires
le collectif nous tout se bat d'ailleurs
toujours pour le retour d'un lieu
d'accueil dédié pour les femmes à
lorient le rendez vous est donné l'année
prochaine le 8 mars pour constater ou
non une évolution de notre société sur
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et puis à paris regardez ces images de
la chaîne parisienne télé bocal
c'était une manif pour les droits des
femmes qui est partis de port-royal
jusqu'à république écoute est d'ailleurs
l'une de ces manifestantes
pas sûr que comme moi je mourrai ceci
l'été sera égalitaire celles qui croient
pas mais la société est faite par les
hommes et pour les hommes donc nous on
est là à demander nos droits en
attendant qu'on nous les donne
on reste toujours dans une actualité
très féminine décidément cette semaine
et on prend la direction de la sa voie
pour aller découvrir une piste olympique
de bobsleigh
c'est là que deux beaux buzz c'est comme
cela qu'on les appelle s'entraîne dans
cette fin de saison
les deux nouvelles pépites de la
discipline rêve de représenter la france
dans moins d'un an aux jeux olympiques
d'hiver de pékin et il s'agirait là
d'une première pour un équipage français
en bobsleigh féminin la chaîne 8 mont
blanc nos partenaires sur place les ont
rencontrés regarder ce début du mois de
mars marque la fin d'une longue saison
pour margot boeck et carla sénéchal pour
margot la pilote originaire de la plagne
écart à la pousse aux chambérienne cette
saison 2020 2021 et surtout celle de la
confirmation à respectivement 21 et 24
ans les deux beaux gosses du team france
ont clairement franchi un palier cette
année
pour preuve pour leur première
participation à des mondiaux seniors de
bobsleigh en février dernier leur 15e
place finale ne les a pas totalement
satisfaite contente parce qu'on a pu
prendre de l'expérience on a pu faire
trois belles descentes
on commence à avoir on peut se placer au
niveau des meilleurs après un peu déçu
parce que d'une part il ya une manche
qui a été ratée donc forcément de la
déception puisque on voulait accrocher
un top 10 pour margot box sacrée
championne du monde des moins de 23 ans
au mois de janvier avec madison stringer
d'une autre co équipière la progression
est même fulgurante
elles veulent pas être le premier
équipage féminin du bobsleigh français à
se qualifier pour les jeux olympiques en
je pense qu'on va aller très loin parce
qu'on est ambitieuse et très motivé on
est prêtes à tout pour pour performer
pour réaliser notre rêve
et pourtant rien ou pas grand chose me
prédestiné ces deux grandes sportives à
se rencontrer et encore moins à faire
équipe en juillet 2018 margot qui a
décidé de quitter la luge pour le
bobsleigh contact via les réseaux
sociaux carla qui pratiquent
l'athlétisme pour lui présenter son
projet un peu fou de participer un jour
aux jo c'est un véritable coup de foudre
professionnel et d'estimé entre elles
est totalement réciproque c'est une
personne extraordinaire qui est vraiment
dévoués qui fait tout pour réussir et
vraiment je suis admirative elle est
très jeune elle est déterminée elle sait
ce qu'elle veut et pour moi c'est
quelqu'un qui ira loin
autant dans le sport que dans sa vie
puisque m6 où elle va et elle sait ce
qu'elle a envie et c'est le plus
important
cette aventure sportive c'est
aujourd'hui transformée en une véritable
aventure humaine pour margot boc carla
sénéchal qui partagent tout six mois
dans l'année est aujourd'hui plus que
jamais l'addition de ces deux grands
talents fait grandir le sport féminin
français et puis toujours à propos de
cette journée internationale des droits
des femmes regardez ces images de nos
partenaires de la provence en à peine
quelques secondes ces féministes vont
devoir coller leurs phrases sur les murs
des rues marseillaise depuis l'année
dernière et avec le couvre feu
c'est colleuse n'ont d'autre choix que
d'agir en plein jour aux yeux de tous
une action militante pour dénoncer les
violences sexistes et sexuelles faites
aux femmes ayant pour but de susciter la
réaction des passants
elles sont peut-être obligé de le faire
parce qu'on les entend pas
dans les médias et dans la société
normale et du coup je suis contente de
voir les personnes qu'ils font ça en
tout cas moi je les ai vus donc si moi
je l' ai vu d'autres l'ont eu
et si je m'arrête c'est que d'autres
dossiers arrêté même par le regard et
puis nous avons une page sports
maintenant dans ce grand j'y tenais
territoire avec la fameuse course
cycliste paris-nice qui est parti
dimanche dernier depuis les yvelines
c'est la commune de saint cyr l'école
qui a lancé l'événement
puis ce fut au tour de ou un vil sur
mons yankee ensuite accueilli épreuve
cette petite commune du nord des
yvelines de 1100 habitants organisent
pour la première fois de son histoire le
départ de la course au soleil tv 78
étaient bien sûr dans le peloton après
saint cyr l'école c'est au tour de
watteville sur mansion d'accueillir
l'épreuve ce lundi 8 mars
cette petite commune du nord d i mean
2100 habitants organisent pour la
première fois de son histoire le départ
de la course au soleil on a besoin voilà
d'être accueillis dans des villes et
elles le font très bien il ya le gratin
mondial qui hélas et c'est le charme du
vélo de pouvoir faire ça on pourra pas
emmener le psg de wever ville
surmontions ni l'équipe de france de
football mais on peut emmener les
meilleures records ces églises du monde
alors on sait que vous êtes un passionné
de cyclisme ça vous fait quoi de voir
ses coureurs des paris-nice est
caen-lyon ici dans votre ville vous avez
une aja dans pas mal de villes comme je
suis pas mal le tour de france mais les
voir dans ma commune c'est une carte et
personnels fierté collective pour notre
commune pour la mettre en valeur pour la
valoriser mais je regarderai un grand
souvenir en tant qu'élu bonjour michel
picaud l'entreprise française ovh a été
victime d'un incendie dans la nuit de
mardi à mercredi dernier dans ses data
center de strasbourg aucune victime mais
des dégâts importants qui n'empêche pas
le leader européen du cloud computing de
poursuivre son développement
spectaculaire
ovh cloud c'est une réussite française
dont vous nous parler aujourd'hui
bonjour cyril bonjour à toutes et à tous
aujourd'hui vous et moi entrepreneurs ou
pas d'ailleurs nous avons des documents
des vidéos des photos de sites internet
et j'en passe quelque part hébergés dans
un serveur informatique dans le monde
c'est immonde serveurs que l'on appelle
aussi des data center sont en quelque
sorte les poumons d'internet qui héberge
et fournissent des accès au réseau
mondial
quelques géants américains et chinois se
sont accaparés de cet immense marché
mais en europe le leader et français il
s'appelle ovh cloud
il a vu le jour en 1999 à roubaix
l'entreprise a été créée par un jeune
étudiant octave klaba
il commence timidement avec quelques
ordinateurs regroupe en un seul lieu
pour stocker les données des autres
aujourd'hui ces data center diana trente
cinq au total et il couvre 200 pays
ovh envisage désormais de développer de
nouveaux services par exemple le jean
français veut racheter blade une
entreprise française qui a inventé
l'ordinateur sans ordinateur puisque
toutes vos infos et logiciels sont
stockées dans le cloud donc pas dans la
machine des solutions aujourd'hui que
proposent les géants américains comme
microsoft ou encore google
demain qui sait à un serveur mail est
une suite de logiciels made in france
capable de rivaliser avec les géants
mondiaux c'est possible il faudra covéa
grandissent à au fait si j'ai oublié de
vous dire qu au vh ça veut dire en bon
français on vous héberge n'allez pas
chercher plus loin
merci michel picaud au rendez vous dans
une prochaine édition du grand jt des
territoires le ministre de l'agriculture
julien de normandie
et la ministre de la culture roselyne
bachelot était en forêt de bercé
vendredi dernier l'office national des
forêts leur a présenté les huit arbres
d'exception choisi pour la
reconstruction de la flèche de la
cathédrale notre-dame de paris à un
moment hautement symbolique que laure
girard et anthony python pour lm tv
sortes ont vécu pour nous regarder une
horde de journalistes en plein coeur de
la forêt de bercé et deux ministres pour
acter le prélèvement de 8 chêne
bicentenaire
ils vont servir à reconstruire la base
de la flèche de notre dame de paris
partis en fumée dans l'incendié le 15
avril 2019
on avait besoin de très gros arbres de
plus d'un mètre de diamètre et de 20
mètres de longueur avec une légère
courbe placé au bon endroit
voici le premier parmi huit arbres
prélevés dans cette forêt d'exception en
tout il faudra mille spécimens issus de
toutes les régions de france pour
arriver à bout du chantier de la flèche
et du transept des chênes plantées il y
a plus de 200 ans
la responsable du site dans cette forêt
de bercé les expliquer que c'est la
quinzième génération de sylviculteurs
qui prennent soin de ses beaux chênes
pour un jour qu'il puisse être utilisé
un patrimoine que la ministre de la
culture inscrit aussi dans l'avenir
cette aventure inédite dans son ampleur
sera une occasion exceptionnelle de
mettre en valeur la beauté de ce métier
des pratiques de pointe qu'ils
impliquent les chaînes de bersée seront
prélevés jusqu'au 15 mars
ils seront livrés sur le chantier de
notre dame de paris dans un an
voilà vous avez vu ces images
spectaculaires tout à l'heure dans les
titres de ce journal
le 1er décembre 2020 alain qui pesait
près de 300 kg a été évacué par grue de
son appartement de perpignan pour être
hospitalisé il se trouve actuellement à
la clinique du château de vergnes et la
dépêche du midi
aller à sa rencontre il va déjà beaucoup
mieux il a perdu près de 100 kilos
depuis son évacuation spectaculaire
écoutons le
moi j sont pas de cet accord j'arrive
pas 90 kg je sais que je vais arriver
façon je m'attends sportif au ciel tout
le jeu je voyais à l'amour j'attends des
mamans je voudrais pas là moi je
l'attendais nous partons à présent dans
ce journal dans les hauts de france où
près de cinquante six hélicoptères et
350 soldats américains participent à une
opération baptisée mousquetaires
l'objectif menée par l'armée américaine
là-bas et de relever les troupes basées
en europe et de tester les installations
du port de dunkerque et de l'aérodrome
de marck en calaisis sur le littoral des
hôtes france ils vont se rendre dans des
zones d'entraînement en allemagne en
pologne en lettonie tous les neuf mois
c'est l'armée américaine qui procède à
cette relève de ses troupes en europe
était dernier d'ailleurs cette opération
s'était déroulée à la rochelle
regardez ce reportage de caroline
fichten pour ueo la chaîne de la voix du
nord
des hélicoptères de l'armée américaine
comme celui ci est les reports de marque
c'est une première cet appareil fait
partie des cinquante six hélicoptères
qui transiteront par ici dans le cadre
d'une opération logistique de relève des
troupes américaines basées en europe
le china 47 il peut embarquer 32
personnes
sa principale mission c'est le transport
d'équipements lourds assurer le
transport de matériel et du personnel
tous les neuf mois l'armée américaine
procède à la relève de ses troupes l'an
dernier c'est par la rochelle que les
militaires avaient transité pendant une
à deux semaines le matériel arrivée à
dunkerque dont des hélicoptères des
camions et des contenaires va transiter
vers calais pour ensuite être acheminés
en allemagne et en pologne deux cents à
chaque fois que les états unis envoient
leurs forces armées dans le cadre de
l'opération atlantique résolvent on
cherche toujours de nouveaux endroits
de nouvelles options pour qu'on puisse
en cas de crise en cas de besoin amener
des équipements via des ports différents
partout dans le monde cette opération
logistique américaine est organisée en
collaboration avec les autorités
françaises et différents ministères sont
concernés celui des affaires étrangères
et de l'intérieur bien sûr mais aussi
celui de la transition écologique des
solidarités la santé et le ministère de
l'économie
regardez maintenant ces images d'une
nouvelle vedette qui est arrivé en
principauté
saad vedette c'est un catamaran qui va
bientôt assurer une liaison maritime
nouvelles sur la riviera
vanessa décide de monaco info a assisté
à l'inauguration en présence de la
famille princière
il s'agit du moyen le plus efficace pour
relier les deux ports en moins d'un
quart d'heure c'est ce qui a poussé la
société d'exploitation des ports de
monaco de privilégier l'accès par la mer
en se dotant d'une navette maritime à
grande vitesse de plus sa forme
aérodynamique unique lui permet de
réduire de moitié sa consommation par
rapport à un bateau traditionnel la
technologie veut que la navette plus
elle va vite plus elle se soulève
puisque l'air passe en dessous de la
coque et la soulève donc il reste très
peu et reste à peu près 30 centimètres
des deux ailes qui sont dans qu'ils sont
sur l'eau comme des comme des foils
monaco one a été baptisé par sa marraine
camille gottlieb son association by cei
pourrait rendre disponible cette navette
pour les jeunes en dehors de ces
horaires habituels passionné depuis
toujours par la mère la fille de la
princesse stéphanie se sent extrêmement
touché par cet engagement est d'être
marraine de ce bateau pour moi ça prouve
qu'en fait on fait vraiment confiance et
je commence à avoir des responsabilités
au brossage monaco et ça me fait
vraiment vraiment beaucoup plaisir est
d'autant plus par rapport aux
partenariats it be safe
il est reconnaissable entre tous par la
couleur ocre spectaculaire de ses terres
le lac du salagou doit son existence à
son barrage mise en eau le 4 mars 1969
il est située dans l'hérault et retient
quelque 102
lyon de mètres cubes d'eau ouvrage
visant à protéger les populations des
crues du fleuve
il doit subir tous les dix ans une étude
de danger et c'est un robot subaquatique
visant à vérifier l'étanchéité de
l'ouvragé qui s'en charge
regardez ce reportage spectaculaire
devient occitanie sur place plongée en
eaux profondes pour ce robot
subaquatique équipés de caméras optique
de caméras acoustique et d'un sonar sa
mission est d'inspecter le barrage du
salagou
c'est des ondes acoustiques qui vont
taper ce qu'on veut diagnostiquer et du
coup le retour nous donne des images en
temps réel sur sur nos écrans même avec
une une visibilité nulle ou le plongeur
lui ne verrait pas 2 cm avec ça on a une
vision une vision très claire de ce qui
se passe devant dont là par exemple on a
on a une grille qui est section
rectangulaire d'un mètre de diamètre qui
permet de faire descendre un humain aux
besoins en période de vidange
mais de vidange il n'y a jamais eu
l'équipe de cousteau présente pour la
première inspection a laissé place aux
robots subaquatique avec un avantage
certain que village et le barrage ça
dure plusieurs mois et surtout leur
empire c'est entre 2 et 4 ans pour un
barrage de 5 millions de mètres cubes
d'eau cette opération de contrôle ap les
études de danger est obligatoire et doit
être renouvelé tous les dix ans donc on
vient on sculpte et le parement qui est
noyé derrière moi qui ai sous à peu près
50 m dos pour après derrière s'il y en
avait un défaut avoir un diagnostic qui
permettrait d'avoir peut-être d'engager
des travaux en fonction des conclusions
qu'on pourrait qu'on pourrait faire
chaque année en moyenne 200 mille euros
sont investis par le département de
l'hérault dans le barrage du salagou et
son lac à la fois touristique outils
d'irrigation et de protection des
populations
vous le savez c'est la boisson la plus
consommée au monde
y aura-t-il un café 100% martinique et
qui pourrait séduire bientôt les
connaisseurs le parc naturel régional de
la martinique
organisé en tout cas à la dégustation de
la première récolte de café arabica
tipica c'est son nom la plantation est
lancé depuis trois ans sur des parcelles
expérimentales pour relancer la filière
de
production de café sur l'île tout est
possible à long terme l'objectif est
d'en faire un café d'excellence un
reportage sur place de atv martinique
nos confrères et partenaires pour
certains il est difficile de démarrer la
journée sont lui le café rituel du matin
se reconnaît à sa couleur son odeur et
son goût celui ci est un produit
purement martiniquais un café arabica
tipica avec ses spécificités
bah moi tu horrifié quand ils sont 21
mais ce n'est pas qu'à fictional sommes
un peu plus de subtilité met de
l'intensité aromatique aussi bien
extrait cyr se motiver sans cette
dégustation et le moment de découvrir le
résultat de cette première récolte
d'ailleurs cultiver ce qu'a fait de
manque quelques particularités
ce qu'a fait assez difficile à cultiver
parce qu'on n'utilise pas de produits
oncolytiques arriver au but final qu'on
veut allumer l'excellence un café
d'excellence pour le parc naturel de
martiniquais la filière est prometteuse
et avoir un café d'excellence est
apporté de grands nous voulons
développer tout incident hier avec de
nouveaux métiers autour de ce projet
toute la martinique ne crois pas se
lancer vers cette filière d'excellence
est puisqu'il ya des critères à
respecter mais nous pouvons penser un
développement de la filière café avec
d'autres types de café valorisation de
la filière café de la filière cacao la
martinique serait telle fertile aux
produits d'exception voilà après les
antilles on se rend du côté de la
nouvelle aquitaine maintenant dans ce
gîte et dans le centre-ville de limoges
plus précisément place fournier des
archéologues fouillent depuis le mois de
février et le recherche se révèle bien
fructueuse
un four un mur d'enceinte et une
centaines de squelettes du xiiie siècle
viennent d'être dévoilées à seulement 40
centimètres de la surface de la rue ce
sont des images réalisées sur place par
nos partenaires de la chaîne 7 à limoges
à la fin du 12e au début du xiiie siècle
se sont installés des tombes et on a
tout
un vaste cimetière qui se développe ici
donc on a pour l'instant peut-être une
centaine de tombes qu'on a pu mettre au
jour
on reste sans nouvelles aquitaine pour
découvrir ce reportage qui va intéresser
les amateurs de belles voitures
vous allez le voir elles deviennent
accessibles pour tous ou presque
les voitures de location sont souvent
des biens rares et onéreux pourtant il
est possible de les louer pour un
week-end ou pour une journée sans passer
par un garage une start-up bordelaise a
eu l'idée et propose la location de ces
automobiles anciennes en mettant en
contact directement
le propriétaire avec le locataire à la
manière de la plate forme de logement
est remis et demi cet art portage de tv7
la chaîne du groupe sud ouest sur place
retrouver le goût des vacances au volant
d'une vieille voiture et profiter de la
route
c'est le programme du week end pour ce
jeune couple en est fraîchement marié
pas les frontières sont fermées et
difficile est parti en voyage de noces
alors validé vue assez spontanément en
fait de plutôt rester en france est de
découvrir la france
il est différent une expérience de
conduite réserver sur internet qui leur
revient un peu plus de 300 euros
lancé il ya un an et demi la plateforme
propose plus de 600 voitures en location
par delà de la populaire 4l de chevaux à
des voitures que l'on peut mettre quand
catégorisé comme comme lui et jaguar
type e
c'est très sentimental pour un bon
nombre d'utilisateurs avant de se lancer
sur la route propriétaire et clients se
rencontrent pour une prise en main de
l'automobile un moment de partage qui
séduit ce collectionneur c'est une
occasion d'être associés à des
événements heureux parce que très
souvent nos voitures sont loués pour des
mariages en même temps ça me permet de
participer aux frais d'entretien
la plateforme touche 20% sur chaque
location et aimerait rendre disponible
3000 voitures de collection d'ici 2022
le plus grand karaoké de france va
bientôt ouvrir ses portes à cap malo
alors qu'elle est la première chanson
que vous souhaitez chanter c'est un
reportage de justin baro pour tvr nos
partenaires en bretagne le plus grand
karaoké de france s'apprête à ouvrir à
la mézière sur la zone commerciale de
cap malo musical un multiplexe de 1000
m² termine les finitions des douze
salles privatif pour s'essayer à la
chanson ainsi que de l'espace bar et
concert située de l'autre côté de
l'établissement séduit bride est le
fruit du rêve de la famille kameda
installé dans le pays de rennes depuis
dix ans on a réussi à avec mon épouse et
mon enfant à créer un endroit qui est
celui dans lequel on aurait aimé aller
tout musical encore en chantier
on peut déjà se faire une idée du
résultat final alors vous allez pouvoir
venir chanter donc ici vous allez avoir
un écran dans le haut de chaque côté
une enceinte sur la partie gauche vous
avez un autre ipad qui va vous permettre
de commander votre boisson votre
snacking un catalogue de 40 mille
chansons et promis par les propriétaires
des lieux pour deux heures de karaoke
les prix par personne varie en fonction
du jour de la semaine de 12 euros à
lundi par exemple à 20 euros un soir de
week-end
voilà on se rend en corse maintenant
dans ce grand jt des territoires entre
calvi et l'île rousse cela s'appelle la
lithothérapie et cela permet d'améliorer
son bien-être physique et émotionnel
cette créatrice a pour objectif de
soigner les maux par les pierres on
écoute cette créatrice interviewé par
via télévisées dont confrères de la
chaîne tnt corse
on va utiliser en fait la fréquence et
l'énergie des minéraux pour pouvoir
permettre au corps de cinq rainier et de
raisonner avec les pierres pour
améliorer à la fois son bien-être
physique et aussi son bien-être
émotionnel et le parc naturel marin du
cap corse et de la grille at a lancé un
vaste projet d'étude de recensement et
de cartographie des grottes marines
présentes dans son périmètre pour le
moment 27 de ces grottes ont été
dissociées en deux groupes distinctes
les grottes semi submergé qui présente
une partie aérienne et les grottes
submergé obscures ou semi obscures c'est
sur ce deuxième groupe qu'une équipe de
scientifiques mandatés par le parc a
travaillé cette semaine autour de l'îlot
de la giraglia ce bout de terre le plus
au nord de la corse
voilà merci d'avoir suivi ce grand
journal des territoires sur vos chaînes
régionales et locales de la tnt et sur
tv5 monde
on se retrouve très vite pour une
nouvelle édition
au revoir à tous et bon courage
[Musique]